this is a production of Cornell
University everybody it really is a
privilege and an honor to be here in
front of you all today as some of you
know I've been at the boys Thomson
Institute for 17 years now and I
literally started out taking out the
trash and washing glassware so I've sort
of clawed my way up to the top right so
last year I got her early as last year I
started getting interested in well I
should say since I joined George
jander's lab he works on he's a chemical
ecologist basically and he's worked on
insects read mecha plant insect
interactions for quite a while and just
got into maze about the time that I
started in his lab and about four or
five years ago now so when I was sort of
looking for a project I started thinking
about fall army worm and what a big
problem it's sort of become and so a
little bit about fall army worm
it's a generalist lepidopteran herbivore
that feeds on over a hundred plant
species and but it prefers grasses in
fact most crop plants that are grasses
most cranes feeding occurs primarily in
the world at night and crop losses can
literally approach hundred percent if
not controlled using modified BT
germplasm or using synthetic
insecticides it's the most we know about
the genetic control about it is that
it's a complex trait controlled by at
least seven QTL that explains 48% of the
phenotypic variants so
when I really got into thinking about
this was when fall army woman was
discovered in Africa in 2016 and as of
just as past September this report here
if any of you are interested in this at
all this just came out in September it's
really good and comprehensive and really
scary as to how bad the situation is in
Africa right now
now they've surveyed 54 countries and
it's been found in 28 of these countries
and so it's a huge problem because the
primary management strategy is to
increase pesticide use and if the
chemicals can be obtained especially by
a small farm small holder farmers and so
we know that there's a genetic variance
and thanks to Nick for these photos in
fact this is really I should say this is
really a project that Nick and I are
doing together if it wasn't for him and
heads group for providing me the seed
and Margaret for moving the germ plasm
forward I wouldn't be doing this so I
just want to throw that out there so I
on the left you can see this is B 73
this is whoops this is the reference
genome and it's we it's susceptible to a
farm II worm and on the right this is MP
7 or 6 this is a line that was improved
in Mississippi by Paul Williams and it's
derived from more tropical germ plasm
and and so with the problem in Africa
let me know Nick and I both to ask these
questions what are their genetic factors
that contribute to and are by osis you
know producing chemicals to harm the
pest ant eyes enosis maybe the pestle
just go someplace else or tolerance
where the plant can actually handle
getting attacked and produce grain
and then well what are the biochemical
pathways and compounds conferring
armyworm resistance in maize we know a
little bit about resistance and other
caterpillars and our lab will use
primarily beat army worm and so ours is
the same is it the different
they're pretty closely related but they
the mechanisms could be different and
then how can we leverage the vast
natural diversity found in maize to
address these questions in a rapid
manner because the situation so dire in
Africa and American farmers could use to
serve information too so we started with
when I got talking with Nick about this
and how bad it was in Africa he's like I
have lines I have seed and that I've
improved over about ten years and
they're ready to go to test them and I
said great now I have a project so so
and I hope if hopefully I'm okay on
these genetics so you guys can shout out
or thumb wrong because these were
developed by Nick and the buccal lab and
the initial goal is to develop an early
flowering temperate adapted farming worm
resistant inbred lines to use in the US
because if climate change is real which
I think most of us think it is that
offers an opportunity for the army worm
to expand its range in the US because
well I can't diapause so it can't
survive the winters up here but it does
just fine in South Florida and in South
Texas and then it moves up here in the
summertime and usually gets to western
New York about right around pollination
time mid to late late August so the big
population was the NAMM founders the
NAMM founders are 25 diverse in breads
that were back cross to be 73 to make
recombinant inbred lines so these are
just the the founders of that population
and they were open pollinated in a pail
across block design and they just let it
fly and harvested it and then took all
the seed put it in a in a bin pulled it
and then
planted it out the next season and I
selected for early flowering time for
the next two seasons and then planted it
down in Puerto Rico and selected for
fall army worm resistance under pressure
they are underneath self pollinated for
another six to nine generations to
maximize homozygosity so we also decided
to look at five African accessions 2x
plant variety protection acts accessions
of opposing heterotic ropes or stiff
stock and non-stiff stock so you could
test for combining ability to make
resistant hybrids and so our evaluation
scheme was going to be we wanted to do a
whole plant no choice ese to assess
Caterpillar performance and to survey
damage tissue for induced secondary
metabolites we also wanted to do choice
s I used to distinguish susceptible from
resistant genotypes and things I have in
the queue is that these inbred lines are
currently being sequenced and we hope to
do some gos on them genome-wide
Association studies and then we're also
I'm mostly looking at historical data
from 2015 and 2016 in Puerto Rico to do
some gos on those perhaps so here's the
no choice performance test we have a
chamber at BTI down the basement and we
got some perforated bread bags to hold
the little critters in there we put one
army worm in the world a plant wood
because that's their preferred feeding
site and then let them go for a week and
then we retrieve the caterpillars a week
later and also so we'd weigh them for to
measure performance because if they
don't like the plant they won't feed on
it or they'll feed on it less and then
we also collected the damaged tissue
because specialized metabolites are
usually accumulated the feeding site
that's been found to be true and some
basic studies and so that's in the
future and we also photograph some of
these damaged tissue hopefully to
calculate a damaged leaf area index in
the future with software
and this is about the size so these are
neonates these are about one day old as
soon as they hatched we we put them on
the plants and so here's the results the
red ones are African the cyan ones are
though Knicks lines that he improved the
gray ones are xx plant variety
Protection Act lines then the green ones
the MP 7 or 6 or resisting control and
then the blue one is e 73 the reference
genome and so when I did the ANOVA
analysis
bummer no significant difference so you
know and so you can look at the sample
sizes here they're a little bit all over
the place and you can also see that we
have some extreme outliers here and
these are not entering the data wrong
these were fat caterpillars so so I
think we need to do some more reps or
improve our methods on this this type of
assay so we also want to do a choice
performance test we put 14 inbred leaf
death in a in a tray we put 100 neonates
in there and then did 10 replicates for
most of the hybrids we scored day later
and then measured the number of
caterpillars on a disk and then assign
them a damage score from 0 to 5
and this is you can see that there's
variation between the lines some are
definitely getting munched on more than
others
and some of Nick's lines here are doing
pretty well versus the resistant MP 706
and then when you look at the so the
orange bars are the damaged scores so I
sorted by damage score from least damage
to most damage and then the caterpillar
weights are in cyan and the number of
categories I should say and cyan and
they're kind of all over the place and
there's a hem P 706 and there's b73 and
when I did a anova and a Tukey's HSD
test these three lines MP 706 and to the
improved lines were significantly better
than B 73 and they were not any
significantly different than MP 706 so
these are probably pretty good
candidates to move forward since they do
just as well as the resistant line and
then I've just looked at some historical
data to try and nail down some QTL I'm
going to fly through this because I'm
out of time but basically Nick had some
other scores from the field in Puerto
Rico and we used these scores as a
phenotypic trait to try and map things
with the G wasps and we we had sets from
both the name recombinant inbred lines
and the Mays diversity panel which is
about 280 lines
and then you can see on this is just a
sample from 2013 this is a generalized
linear model with a we were practicing
with tassel I admit and we only use 11
original eleven hundred and forty four
steps from the NAMM set and for the
diversity panel we used our H and V one
hat may have so kind of an outdated
version of step data but you can see
that some Peaks are sort of showing up
I mean it's some are the same and some
are different let's just put it that way
and so the conclusions here is that the
phenotypic data we need to be more
quantitative and because it needs to
show less variance for sure and we could
do that by laughing caterpillars for
weight weighing imaging software
secondary metabolites gene expression
and for the Association mapping the
models need to be improved we need to
run some mix linear models be drawn with
higher snip density and also to account
for kinship and environmental covariance
so thank you guys I couldn't fit every
one I needed to thank on one slide so I
thank you all we have any questions
Rachel oh yeah they don't move around
too much from whatever I'd yeah that's
true no we haven't done that we'd have
to think about that experimental design
how would you do that it would would
either have to have a sealed-off room
with karo but moths flying around
because we don't want them getting out
or yeah that's
would I even thought about that great
idea that's my great question great
question I don't know I don't know how
rapidly these evolved maybe I should
have this discussion with George maybe
he would know well that's a geopolitical
thing right yeah right
no that's that's a great idea
[Music]
yeah there must be BTN breads out there
I don't I don't do you know
yeah yeah right good call well I mean
the MP lines are pretty resistant I mean
but the year right that's not what we
want to be growing in Africa is the
Mississippi ones I don't think maybe I
did try to do I did try to do some
crosses in African germplasm is here in
Aurora and there was just that's growing
degree days were too long
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu